Hi, I'm Alan. I'm owner of a healthy
YouTube channel with over 900,000
subscribers.
So, uh, this is my N workflow that
monitors comments on my videos. So, it
fetches new comments. So, he searchs for
the last published video here using this
API.
After that, get the video ID
and search for comments
in this video.
So, it fetches new comments,
sends send them to the DeepSc AI for
response generation.
This is the filter for the nonresponded
comments.
classify and prepare the answers.
So some of the comments are responded
based on the content of the message of
the comment and other ones they are sent
to the
to a AI agent to answer them.
This is in Portuguese. So answer this
comment in a personalized manner and
also useful. So it must generate a
genuine emp and pic and professional
response
but do not be so specific in the answer
especially in polymic themes.
Okay. So, I'm going to run this to so
you can see how it goes.
This Python script uh downloads
transcripts from my own videos using the
YouTube captions API.
In this case, we have already downloaded
transcripts.
So in this run, we didn't got get any
new video new any transcripts. I'm going
to show the the transcripts folder.
So uh here we have the so we have all
the files from the transcripts.
So this workflow detects new videos and
sends the links to my WhatsApp
health community groups.